[Music]
discriminating against someone for their
political views is already legal in
america
uh you can get kicked off of twitter and
facebook for being a conservative you
can be banned from payment processing
platforms like we pay and block from
raising money on gofundme you can even
be removed from the internet like we saw
with parlor so what's the next step for
political discrimination in this country
so if canada is any indication of what's
next it's being denied mortgages for
your political views
it's just about the nature of the
business all together
because
the bank has been uh i'll be plugged
with you the bank has been
you know trying to pry away from certain
you know clients where
they're
kind of out there in the media and uh
very strong opinionated you know uh
which is your business in a way
so we're just uh clearing some internal
hurdles to make sure that
uh the bank is okay to
that
kind of on board you as a client
internally spoiler alert we did not
clear those hurdles even though i've
done all of my personal banking at that
same royal bank branch for decades
ezreal levant is the man you just saw in
that clip he was speaking to a banker
from the royal bank of canada he is the
founder of rebel news and says he was
denied a mortgage because of his
conservative views ezra levant joins us
now so ezra um the in this in the video
clip we played it wasn't quite clear
if you were being denied because of your
political views or if it's just because
you're a media personality who has a
public presence
what was it
it was very clearly our views
i had several discussions with that
mortgage officer
i just want to make it clear that our
mortgage
application was financially sound
if he would have said it wasn't
financially sound i probably would have
believed him but he was candid with me i
call him a sort of whistleblower he said
it was our opinions because rebel news
the news site that i run has
conservative opinions and the royal bank
is canada's largest bank i should say
they do a lot of business in communist
china and i wonder if they have brought
some of that social credit approach that
they have to use in china
to canada
and by the way they have thousands of
clients in the united states too
and discriminating against people based
on
inappropriate grounds if you're a bank
is called redlining and that's illegal
in the states
i only caught this because this banker
at the local branch really wanted to
give me the mortgage he said he was
fighting against the head office and
that it was the head office that vetoed
this mortgage application i think social
credit as they call it in china or
cancel culture is here in north america
banks in america too remember royal bank
is in america as well
so i don't know this ezra but i was on
the financial services committee when i
was in congress and under the obama era
they had a program called operation
choke point where the federal regulators
the fdic would put pressure on banks to
stop banking gun dealers
smoke shops small dollar lenders and in
essence if you can bank and you know
this as well if you can't bank if you
can't cash checks if you can't process
credit card payments you can't do
business in america so the power of
banking to just live your life is
incredibly powerful if you can't access
it right
yeah and in canada we have far fewer
banks and they have much more power the
royal bank is the largest bank in canada
i should tell you there's a revolving
door between justin trudeau's liberals
and the royal bank uh trudeau's first
ambassador to china was a senior rbc
bank executive he was awful by the way
trudeau just appointed another rbc
executive to the senate so i think it's
a political i scratch your back you
scratch mine rebel news is hated by
justin trudeau we're one of the few
conservative media in this country
trudeau's made that clear it wouldn't
surprise me if the bank was doing him a
favor considering how many favorites he
does them they received you know
canadian banks received enormous
bailouts over the years they get
tremendous privileges uh even more than
u.s banks get and i think this is a
political quid pro quo you don't want
your banks to have a political criteria
when it comes to mortgages i mean really
even convicted murderers when they get
out of jail are allowed to get a bank
account imagine punishing conservatives
and de-platforming them i think this is
a scandal i only found out about it by
accident because i had an honest local
banker i bet you this is more prevalent
than we think i
and how would you know if they never
actually had a whistleblower tell you
ezra you're 100 right but what's
interesting with banking is that they
need the government so in in the states
uh banks have fdic insurance right so if
banks want to be political well politics
can be political as well and if you want
to take away woke banks fdic insurance
or you can take away their charter
they're chartered by the the federal
government or by a state government
those are all tools that conservatives
have when they get into leadership to
address this localism that's happening
in the banking industry we're going to
continue to follow this it is going to
be i think an increasing uh phenomenon
across the country so ezra thanks for
joining me tonight
thank you for having me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else